my compadre from NFL Network Pro
Football Hall of Famer but more
importantly father who's starting
Nebraska wide receiver the dad of Cade
Warner Kurt Warner is here
good to see you me I'm gonna be fired up
about that huh I mean come on now I just
love the game so I know you're kids but
you're do well and a walk-on I know like
you stuck with it he's just he's just a
great kid to I mean that's you know
you've met him I mean that's the coolest
thing is good football player and all
that but he's just a great kid and so
when you have a great kid that does
nothing but work is butt off yeah to
earn that position we're so proud of him
and we're as you said we're excited you
know we're that's what I might not be a
to many of our production meetings this
year nice maybe something that I missed
no eyes I'm gonna try to get to as many
games like that
I bet um you're gonna be all over the
map you do Monday Night Football for on
radio you do our shows you're gonna have
to be as many at those Nebraska games
yeah I'm coaching Friday nights for my
who are my other son is a sophomore in
high school so okay coach in Friday
night which team which team is at Brophy
college prep in in Arizona so we got a
first win last week a nice win force
against the top 10 team so what sorted
start for us what sort of coach are you
discipline or for everybody else that's
like Jimmie Johnson with everybody it's
hard no I mean I think I'm harder on my
kids than I am everyone else okay yeah
you just you know the potential you'll
get there right you see him every day
you know the potential you want them to
be nothing but great so sometimes you
push him a little bit harder but it was
so funny the other day when you tweet
you commented about it on Twitter there
was an actor Robbie Amell who could not
throw even throw properly and it looked
his throw is terrible and he got roasted
on Twitter for throwing this manner in
some some movie and I said I kind of
felt how I understood how he felt cuz of
a Sports Center commercial I was in they
refused to let me wash my hands coming
out of the bathroom for the timing
purposes of the commercial and and so I
understood how this guy was throwing
this way he had to throw this way
perhaps because of the way the cameras
in the
equipment was around for half and so I
perhaps so I said I know how I felt that
I would much rather be known as somebody
you can't throw a football then somebody
who doesn't wash his hands coming out of
the bathroom and what did you say Chris
Brock when you're like well one thing if
you're an actor with that it's another
thing if you're the face of the NFL
Network and you can't throw a football
that is a whole different there's just
an expectation that comes with you know
so much about football and all the stuff
I mean you know you guys know what I
mean
now this is Kurt's favorite pastime he
says he loves football but that's not
much he loves his wife that son today
understandable right underneath that is
tearing me any sort of new one regards
to me there are physical attribute I
might display and you know you know I'm
not a big fan of some of the skits that
we do on but you see Tuesday anything
that we do that's physical that you're
involved yeah I'm all about those skits
on Sunday morning I love those things
for you to come out and you never felt
safer than on the dunk tank with rich
throwing oh yeah there was no chance
when he ran up and pushed it with his
hair there was no she was in there with
the football Kurt Warner you're on the
Rich Eisen show okay I give you the
floor and Andrew Luck's retirement you
thought what when you heard it um well I
mean you know obviously the original
thought was everybody was you know
surprised by the whole thing I think you
know us football fans fan of the
position right fan of guys that carry
themselves the right way and carry the
torch of the NFL disappointed they're
from that standpoint because he's just
he does everything right and I enjoy
watching him play the game so that was
the one side of it the other side of it
fully understand what he's talking about
you know going through the my career the
way that I did whether it was the years
that I was sitting around hoping I could
get back on a football field and play
the times that I got benched and I'm
running scout team or at times when I
went through injuries where it starts to
suck away the love that you have for the
game because what you love is competing
what you love is Sunday afternoons and
when that's taken away from you and it
becomes about everything else you do you
start to wrestle with the idea that I
started playing this game because I love
the game now all these other things are
taking more of my time and attention and
I can't even get to do the thing that I
love to do and so fully understand that
part of it you know and you have to
believe that a lot of people are gonna
say why did it happen now you know why
is it happened two weeks before the
season I feel like a part of it had to
be I don't want to go into another
season where every single week
everybody's wondering is this the week
that Andrew Luck plays and the team has
to answer the questions and Jacobi's got
to wonder am I gonna be the starter this
weekend you know because it's just going
on for so long I almost feel like he was
like I need to step away for the benefit
of the team as well as my benefits who I
can get away and get back to just kind
of loving life again because he's been
through this struggle for so long that's
part of the thing that makes it so sad
and I know again whenever I say man I
feel for him and it's so saddening to me
I get it he's making he made millions
he's getting to keep millions I
understand one of the members of our of
our profession said it's like the most
millennial thing that he couldn't handle
rehabbing all that sort of stuff to me
the fact just knowing of him and knowing
having met him that he sat there Kurt
Warner and thought the only way out of
this was that stop playing football
right had to have been patently
miserable depressing sadness no doubt I
mean I even put on another I remember
when I was benched and I was running the
scout team and they were holding cards
up and saying okay throw to the guy
that's circled and yeah I was making I
was making a lot of money and it was a
great living but I was miserable every
day that I went to work going this is
not why I play this game you know not to
make the money or the fame or order to
last as long as I play because I love
competing
and I love going out there in the X's
and O's and the cat-and-mouse
part of it but I was talking to my was
like I just want to retire I don't want
to be a backup and run scout team that
was natural New York that was actually
in Arizona in Arizona and you know
that's a whole different level cuz it's
not even the rehab and the pain and the
struggle of just being able to to feel
good when you show up to work every day
and you know I know a lot of people out
there like well you make a lot of money
and all I understand that but a lot of
guys don't play for that part of it that
is a huge huge blessing and benefit to
this game is you can set yourself up for
the long haul but some guys aren't wired
just to go oh okay so I don't get to do
what I love to do that's okay because
I'm making a lot of money and that's
what I think a lot of people at home
don't understand is that there's people
out there just play this game because
they love it and if they can't do what
they love they would rather step away
and find something else that they love
to do rather than just come to work
because they can or because they make a
lot of money and I truly believe it when
you heard Andrew Luck talk that was
basically what he was saying is that my
love for the game this other stuff has
become stronger in my mind then my love
for the game and it's why I retired I
think it's why most guys retire is
because you don't want to put in the
time in the offseason anymore that the
preparation part of it the expectation
that comes in - okay you just played a
game and now we expect you to throw for
300 yards and three touchdowns next week
and carry the team those things start to
outweigh your love for the game and that
to me was when it was time for me to
step away when the physical and mental
toll outweighed just enjoying showing up
on Sunday afternoons and and I think we
all come to that point at some time some
earlier than others and I just believe
Andrew Luck with all he's been through
he came to that much earlier than we all
wanted I'm sure more earlier than he
wanted but I understand that feeling and
you know proud that he was willing to
because most guys are gonna just hang
around going man I'm making a lot of
money I'm just gonna try to hang around
and I'm gonna be miserable in the
process that you know that he was able
to to step up and go I'm gonna walk away
from all of this
because I'm not enjoying what I do on a
daily basis few more minutes left with
Kurt Warner actually about four minutes
almost on the head here is it's hard out
you know that being a rail guard oh yeah
so last thing for you it sure looks like
I mentioned New York here here we are in
New York it sure looks like it's the
same situation with you and Eli now with
Eli and Daniel Jones it it it has that
possibility here yeah now Daniel Jones
wasn't drafted as high as Eli you did
not have the whole history with one
single franchise that Eli clearly has
here in New York it's not sure
perfectly apples to apples do you think
we're seeing this play out in some way
shape or form here this year well I
think it has to play out in some way
shape or form but I just think there's a
there's a bigger grace period for Eli
than most guys would get and you know I
don't really know what that looks like
you know I've talked about it a lot with
a lot of people I think Eli has earned
the right to kind of see this thing out
the way that he wants to and that
doesn't mean for the next three or four
years I think for this season because
we've seen what Daniel Jones has been in
preseason if we believe that's what he's
gonna be in the regular season he's
earned the right to kind of play these
16 games but I always reserve the right
to say if there comes a point when the
organization believes Daniel Jones is
the better quarterback hands down
without a doubt you have to make that
decision at that time but outside of
that I believe this is Eli's season to
play out 16 games to show people where
he's at and figure it out from there and
the clean break is to go let him play
the season and then if we believe it's
time we assure that in next year as
opposed to Eli sitting on the bench for
eight seven six games at the end of the
year while Daniel Jones takes over and I
believe that's the perfect scenario but
as we know in this business not a lot of
perfect scenarios that play out did you
see the photograph
after the Bengals Giants game in
Cincinnati where the entire media crowd
like three rows deep boom mics were
around Daniel Jones and off to the side
was Eli just putting his shoes on by
himself what do you think oh yeah what
do you think was going through his mind
based on just well I mean I think
similar things to what went through my
mind when I was in those situations that
here's what I've done and what I've
accomplished yet they can't wait to
replace me and you know what a tough
feeling that is and again mine came in
different ways I mean here's Eli Manning
that's a two-time Super Bowl champion
for this organization that is done that
means it's done everything and been a
model citizen and representation of this
organization but I know the feeling the
feeling is this is the NFL and they are
always looking for the next guy I'm
looking for the guy the heir apparent
the guy to replace you and the young
guys played really well and so I mean I
know Eli's going okay I'm gonna I'm
gonna show them in the next 16 games
that I belong as the starter but every
day you show up to work you say is today
the day is today the day where they make
that move good to see you Kurt Warner on
CD level 100 there this evening all
right I'll see you on NFL gameday
morning season preview show next Tuesday
won't see you in person even though
you'll be part of the Thursday kickoff
show from Chicago where you're calling
it on the radio then I'll see you the
following weekend all right best to
Brenda Warner sir a lot that's the most
important Warner in house man thank you
that's when you're supposed to say you
know best of my series we love you know
we know for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app